Assistive technology is an umbrella
term for a broad range of devices,
software and tools that help any person
with a disability complete a task.
In the broader sense this include
something as low tech as a crutch to
help someone walk or
magnifying glass to assist reading, or
as high tech as a robotic prosthesis or
image recognition software
running on a smartphone.
It can include something as
general as browser zoom or
as specific as a custom-designed
game controller.
It can be a separate physical
device like a braille display, or
be implemented completely in
software like voice control.
It can be built into an operating
system like some screen readers or
it can be an add-on like
a Chrome extension.
And assistive technology in
particular is pretty blurry.
After all, all technologies being built
to assist people with some task or
another, and things often move in and
out of the assistive
technology category.
For example, one of the earliest
commercial speech synthesis products was
a talking calculator for the blind, and
now we see speech synthesis popping up
all over the place, from driving
directions to virtual assistance.
On the other hand,
technology which is general purpose
often finds an assistive use.
For example, people may use
their smartphone's camera zoom
to get a better look at something
small in the real world.
In the context of web development we're
still talking about a diverse range of
technologies that we want to support.
People may interact with your
website using a screen reader or
braille display with a screen magnifier,
via voice control,
using a switch device, or
some other form of assistive technology
which adapts the page to create a more
specific interface that they can use.
For all of these technologies, ensuring
that our website support assistive
technology uses is going to come down to
programmatically expressed semantics.
But before we can explain exactly what
programmatically expressed semantics
refers to, we need to talk
a little bit about affordances.